so this part I completely forgot like I
knew you could be different characters
but I didn't know that was literally
like a character select screen
didn't know that you know what let's
let's roll with Hermione here
the most power I mean she's the most
powerful or should be anyway the
villagers of little hangleton still
called it the riddle house ah the riddle
house half a century ago a servant had
found all three riddles
dead
perhaps if we were to do it
without is that worms hail
I think that's wormsail
they don't even show oh they didn't even
show inside the house just The Voice
I know dude
I would love to werewolves I would love
to
I think there are captions retro guys
I don't want to skip this if I push it
right now I'm afraid it'll skip we'll
check after this
Chad said it was a little loud so
hopefully I didn't go far too far the
other way
oh is it hard to let me okay let me turn
it up I'm just gonna turn it up just
I may have went too much the other way
oh my goodness okay wow
let's get away from the campsite wow
okay so first thing I notice
oh there we do we do have subtitles nice
all right
nice nice nice there we go first thing I
noticed the controls like it just feels
like she is running in in butter like
she continues a good second after I
after I let go
so we pick things up right immediately
after the Quidditch World Cup when
things are going crazy
don't remember this part in the book
Doug bugs oh my gosh and he just
straight up
a rapidly
Harry's just guessing when guardian
levios on it
I mean so I think the thing that
disappointed people the most is they
completely went away from the open World
style
like prisoner mask van introduced the
idea
of being able to play
other characters which was which was
cool they used it in some puzzle
situations
and then with this one they just said
we're just gonna make it like a co-op
non-open world
and so right now I mean I'm just
spamming the a button here
audio levels are great now nice okay
good good
the slide I know it's like
it's just like
don't even know how to describe it
really
yeah butter that's a good
ain't about how fast you get there about
what's waiting on the other side it's
the slide
all right come on guys work together
and by the way the game
normally does not look nearly this good
Dolphin Emulator working its magic here
to make this look even better
yeah the beans are definitely harder to
pick up too
okay wait what is this right here
what is this little pickup
I have no idea but we're gonna grab it
anyway and then we also have like some
sort of meter in the bottom left
yo Dylan what is up Dylan with the
subscription hey thank you so much Dylan
Dylan a moderator over on the YouTube
channel the Discord and also
conveniently here on Twitch as well
I had let them know hey guys I might
stream some on Twitch do you guys have
accounts there let me just make sure all
of you are modded over there
what's going on with the flowers is that
a Hermione thing
you guys seen those flowers the beat
look what is this what is this
kept running from me and then randomly
disappeared all right Hermione's at 100
Health uh looks like she's collected 20
beans
oh wait wait there it is X all players
press the button together for men
magicus
I do not remember this
magicus extremos mode
is this like the early forms of the
ancient magic here
is this the early forms of ancient Magic
all right I'm gonna I'm gonna press it
right now it said the x button
what in the world
so now what is she just like super
powered for a second
are my spells more powerful
ancient magic and fur
oh my gosh dude
hey thank you guys for the follows by
the way welcome welcome to the new
followers I'm guessing new followers
here but probably regular followers over
on the YouTube channel
there we go combine cast
collect blue beans to fill your magic
meter
there you go guys there's where Hogwarts
like is he got the idea
for the ancient magicus extra Moss
that's how they pronounced it
uh Psalm I have played and platinumed
Eldon ring
and I have streamed some of it so I
actually made a second channel
retroacting to her let's plays
where you can view roughly half of my
playthrough
great cast
you see that at the top what is this
like DDR now like is it a timing thing
how do I get the great cast all right
looks like we can't Target that dude up
there so we're just gonna have to hope
that Arthur can hold up oh no Arthur's
just Arthur's just like teleporting
as our guide here
helping us with the trees yeah I'm
really glad you guys are here to help me
through this because I don't know if I
could play this like this is not a game
that I would just play for enjoyment on
my own
it is not a game
yes um like I started one literally just
for like to post Elden ring Let's Plays
and then if I ever do
more let's play so like YouTube man the
algorithm is so
it's really interesting like the
audience who prefers let's plays
is it necessarily
I know some of you like you probably
enjoy the Let's Plays and love them on
the main Channel
but the way that it treats certain
videos like they could just never get
seen by anybody so I kind of test it out
make it a second channel to post Let's
Plays but I haven't really done many
Let's Plays since then so but I'd love
to hear your all your thoughts on that
like if you're just like hey just keep
them on one channel
I think it has to do with timing like
the fact that let's plays are such
they're they're really long videos
[Music]
I have no idea what's going on like like
these dug bugs all just
okay looks like our health is still good
thankfully
Hermione spells have some sort of like
flower effect
that appear out of them
how we only have 37 beans I have no idea
because
wait am I supposed to levitate them oh
dude can I like can we drop this rock on
him oh that'd be so awesome if he could
oh
okay forget forget the Rock
Abba Force oh Ron getting all fancy over
here on us some Transfiguration
don't remember the attack of the dug
bogs right
this is the worst water game
could be interesting to watch
to help you a little there's a button
that enabled the accio spell that
attracts beans to you what
is this like an options thing or I have
to do I have to uh
this is something I have to get later
by the way guys Ray attire
is um Nico from YouTube
foreign
that might take some getting used to
Nico
like Dylan's is pretty close McD
wait can I not attack
come on get that Death Eater up there
Ron is getting caught swapped that boy
need to get it together
oh that's too funny welcome q s t
welcome welcome
oh my gosh so Hermione found a 61 Health
okay I need to quit goofing off
yeah it took a bite out of me too
great cast like
the game never gives you any indication
to like what is a great cast or not
yo and a tier one subscription or no
Amazon Prime subscription yo thank you
so much for that cue
very much appreciated
yeah guys so for those of you who uh
normally followed
I just not Ron out with The Rock
what the heck dude
for those of you who normally check out
the YouTube stuff it's a little bit
different like the way the naming works
on Twitch so here a follow is the
equivalent of a subscription so anyone
can follow the Channel free you'll be
notified when streams go live that sort
of thing
um but if you want for ad-free viewing
and to unlock the emotes here which I
actually I need to update the emote dude
why is the rock like come on
the guardian Leviosa Hermione like it
shouldn't just immediately knock me out
um but yeah so here a subscription it is
it's like a paid thing whereas YouTube
the subscriptions are free but if you
have Amazon Prime you can subscribe for
free
which is what um qst did there
how are we going to get past that Death
Eater
come on Harry get over here dude Red
Tractor
and Harry just Falls over too
retract them
oh
where is it that's the dark mark
that's the talk mark
[Music]
10 a.m and he has energy
yeah it's uh it's about 9 50 a.m oh
trust me I Norm I'm not a morning person
not a morning person but I had to uh my
wife was working today and my kids were
back to school
so I had to get up at about 6 50.
to get my oldest son ready
and then take my oh dude great cast
Perfect cast combined cast
I feel so rewarded but I have no idea
how we did any of these things
all right so Hermione got 57 beans Harry
I think had two come on guys get with
the bean collecting step it up
been awake since 1am you feel dizzy oh
my goodness dude you better rest
6 50 a.m for oh my gosh for Nico
in such a z what is up dude welcome
[Applause]
no Perfect cast I know dude I failed
miserably
five of the house Edition books they got
up to 40 50 a piece oh my goodness
that's crazy Saul I have the first I
have the first
um Illustrated Edition
of the first book
not the house Edition like the big one
that's like the The Illustrated ones
they're really awesome actually really
awesome
all right so I guess that's like your
tutorial level
inspector I don't know the controls the
console versions oh push some buttons on
the GamePad oh okay I'll try
you have to hold that button in order to
use it efficiently missed the tutorial
on that spell at the beginning what
have one and it just completely bypassed
it
oh dude so yeah you get to this moment
and you realize oh wait there's no open
world in this game
it's all level based so there's I guess
that was the tutorial we're done with
that so there's one two
three
or
five
there is there's a delay on every one of
these six
seven
eight
nine
ten that's it so you get 10 levels
you get 10 levels in this game no open
world
which honest honestly with the engine
and the way things run in this game
that may actually be a a mercy
so you did get some Collectibles here we
have zero out of 38 of something over
there in the top left
let's see if I hit more info again
dark detectors mushrooms Taps shovels
gargoyles
so they don't even have accio oh wait oh
my goodness okay hold on hold on
are these all of the Spells you have in
the game you just have them right from
the beginning
yeah it was a big disappointment Cosmic
radiation oh my goodness how have you
been Cosmic
thank you thank you yeah it's uh
the YouTube's been going really well
but yeah I I still I miss I miss the
gaming live streams too Cosmic
how's your son doing
I haven't talked dude Cosmic radiation
another regular regular back when we
streamed here
we used to play a lot of Destiny
together as well 38 days till February
10th oh my goodness it's insane dude
it's insane how close we are
I have not played the Minecraft Harry
Potter map Walton but I've heard I've
heard a lot of good things about a
couple of them I don't know if there's
like a definitive one but the one that I
keep seeing pull us what in the world I
don't think I've ever heard that spell
did they just start making them up at
this point ebublio duck lefores inflatus
I I feel like they just started going
with whatever at this point
I mean wouldn't pull us I mean wait why
would you just use accio or Carpe
retract them
all right so you do have some
Collectibles it appears
let's see uh collector cards do we have
any of these yet
so Harry has no cards oh but there's a
set
Hermione's cards I thought it said I got
one with Hermione but it could just be
wrong
foreign
nope dude everything in this game is
laggy everything in this game is laggy
it is crazy all right let's just back
out let's just get into this next level
here
that's just getting to the next level
oh dude Nico it's good to know our uh
looks like our bot works for the for
twitch streams too if we go live on
Twitch
all right let's stick with Hermione
again
let's see comment there from inspector
question about the flower effect it's a
spell called orc orchidius
this is one of the spells that appear in
this game and never mentioned in other
games automatically used yeah I realized
it didn't actually give me the name of a
spell it was just like
just press a
wait what am I supposed to do here oh I
don't have any cards this character is
no collectors cards you can buy cards
for them by selecting collector's cards
on the level select screen and where we
already checked that there was nothing
there
or you can equip character cards
interesting
oh I don't think we have any for any of
them all right
Harry Ron and Hermione met Mad Eye Moody
for an extra defense against the doctor
should be in Hogwarts Legacy
oh the jack-o'-lantern spell beyond
that's right uh
I didn't I didn't remember if they ever
had a name for it wondering why I
brought you here are you
welcome to the new follows guys thank
you
oh my goodness
Elder Ringo's your second Platinum nice
that's a good one that's that's actually
a really fun fun Platinum like if you're
into the game
okay Jinx the bucket for beans keep your
eyes
all right somebody said to spam
maybe that's it right there triangle
is that accio
or is that supposed to be lumos
okay
or why I'm using I'm using my
PlayStation controller with Gamecube um
button prompts
hey wait let me try some other buttons
here
we haven't got all day so besides
metaphors the others are completely made
up
oh my goodness
this whole game in East Dragon Hogwarts
Legacy
hey zielman's welcome
I know dude this like I can't even
remember if I beat this game I
definitely remember playing it
and I remember being super frustrated at
points the water level I remember the
second task was just
a big time pain okay same enemies that
we already fought
after the Quidditch World Cup come on
there you go Hermione
it's weird like this game went oh wait
let me see if this actually
is that actually somebody said I need to
learn accio
I don't think that's it though
oh wait they want me to lift him now
there we go got him
and he just he just vanishes
when you do wingardium levios on him
I may shadow guy that's a good question
yeah
I feel like some people might like to
see
oh wait is this a collectible
you see that white thing like right in
the Forefront of the screen
I don't know
okay so if I hold down
does do a stronger cast
[Music]
no uh that's prisoner of ass command
sealman this one picked up right after
the Quidditch World Cup
when everything's going crazy and then
it's broken up into levels so the next
level
is this one you're already at Hogwarts
oh my goodness dude Harry
let me help you hurry
oh never mind you got it under control
like what is even happening right now
like what Moody just
so sometimes when I cast when guardian
Leviosa they spontaneously combust and
other times they don't
I still can't figure out if this Spell's
meant to be lumos right here
yeah prisoner Azkaban is pretty solid
but this one
had all sorts of problems
all right let me help you Harry
there you go
we're just gonna spam all right let's
see does this absorb through to the to
them no I don't think so and we're
losing
we're losing beans quickly
all right so our health stands at 88
Hermione 66 Harry and 80 for Ron
dude I don't even think I care about
collectibles in this game I think I just
want to get to the end so what's the
point of these rocks over here so I
supposed to use these to do battle
by the way guys though we did discover
if you look down there in the bottom
left
the early form of the ancient magic
meter from Hogwarts Legacy
they called it um something extra most
oh here we go
it is why
you're going to need a chocolate frog
okay I'm holding one oh there we go dude
remember you can summon rewards that are
Out Of Reach
Co
axio they pronounced it axio in this one
all right nothing like wizard Suites
who is that who's that talking all of a
sudden is that oh that's Moody I guess
it's still supposed to be moody
there you go silver they did have the
tutorial for it
another hydrate
another hydrate welcome to New follows
guys thank you
all right let's see if I can get beans
out of these okay good at least that
carried over right
but they're all just did you see that
they just kind of like vanish into the
wall
can I summon them back return to me
beans return
there we go there we go
come on beans
all right I don't even know if you're
gonna be able to get anything worthwhile
with them in this game but
I still enjoy collecting beans
still enjoy the bean collecting
always love looking at the portraits in
these games
cause it's like who did they use is this
their their kids their family their
friends I know they did that some of the
developers are in uh
philosopher's stone
aqua erecto
can't say that I've heard of that one
before either
all right so that was it that's level
one complete
great cat oh my goodness guys no great
cast no Perfect cast no combined cat I
mean I guess we've just failed
we have completely failed at this point
oh okay so we did get nine new cards
awarded so we should for sure have some
cards this time
basically augmenti
Aqua e roughton i
director
oh my God
why would they do that did this one not
have to get approved by
Joe's people
because I know what the first three they
had to I mean
she provided all of the Spells
maybe this one was just under such a
time crunch they just had to be like
okay whatever
Just Go With It
oh let's see if Dumbledore freaks out
does he freak out in the game
oh no did we just freeze
oh good
I thought it froze
you have to buy the cards yeah I I think
that's what it said
so do I go in here
all right let's let's just start with
Harry
okay there we go yeah so you buy them
with uh
all right so do I share oh you do not
share beans so you need to play as
different people Harry only had 10 beans
so Hermione should have the most okay
she's got 175.
bro
why are hermiones more hold on if Rons
are 20
oh
why why are Hermione's cards 50
what the heck
it's just because I have more beans with
her isn't it
increases the duration of magicus
extremus Plus 10.
oh wow okay that's they all do the same
yep yep they all do the same thing
so you could see there were some I'm not
gonna say good ideas but there were
there was a seed of some good ideas here
okay that's actually
that's kind of cool you get a little
shot of the movies there
I still don't know did they not just do
normal wizard cards though
see who this one is
Dumbledore
there he is
limit lad what is up
first theory is that aqua eructose water
appears to be water from the sea
interesting
Harry Potter
I know I would have I'm disappointed
they didn't have the Dumbledore freak
out in the game that's kind of sad
it's such an iconic moment all right so
all of Hermione's cards so far featuring
our boy Dumbledore here
Albus Percival wulfric Brian Dumbledore
all right [ __ ] can we buy any with Ron
I don't think we have enough with Ron
either 17. all right so this kind of
does encourages you to play with all the
characters especially if you wanna
unlock everything
I know silver
that's completely unfair
once Bell delivers clean drinking water
other uses salt water from the sea there
you go
all right listen to defense against the
dark arts dude how can you beat this
game in like a few hours
we might be able to beat it
all right I'm gonna be uh Harry this
time
so we can buy some of his cards okay so
we have no cards for Harry fine Hermione
we should have three cards
yep that one
wait 10. okay it's just telling me that
and then the last one we want
uh that nope nope nope that one there we
go
increases the duration okay so this
magickus extremus guys this super
powerful
Flow State for wizards that we've never
heard about until the god of fire video
game
oh yeah quite a few Cosmic Hogwarts
obviously a big one for sure
Zelda
for sure
star field
um I want to play I want to play the
Star Wars game too
which conveniently enough
um the first one is on oh dude look at
that ancient magic meter now that's what
I'm just gonna call it that from now on
the old school the OG ancient magic
meter right here
Dumbledore freaking out yeah the game
probably would have uh
relax Moody relax for two seconds and
let me just converse with the chat here
for a moment
my goodness
to be fair Hermione has Rich parents
so I mean so did Harry right he was
loaded
if anything runs I mean Harry's were the
cheapest I believe
magic I mean right it it equals the
ancient Magic
Jedi Fallen orders a must play
incredible yeah I've heard really good
things
I've heard really good things about it
and now it's on PlayStation plus it's
just a perfect time perfect time
and then
um the next one comes out right after
the month after Hogwarts Legacy so it
would just be like a perfect little
lead-in
we uh you know do everything there is to
do with Hogwarts Legacy
you know what I'm
time to play and stream it before
Hogwarts comes out
if you play until the second task play
it one time then download a completed
100 save and then play the rest of the
levels and you can pass it in a couple
of hours try to collect 40 plus Shields
after the second task artificially
extends the game's hours interesting
if you play hold on I'm not sure I'm
following you inspector
play it one time
oh like if you're trying to collect
everything or are you saying you're not
saying there's like some game breaking
glitch right
I remember the second task was a pain
I remember it was a huge huge pain
all right B to put out the fire
aqua
all right we gotta get Harry some beans
this time
beans cast accio
accio for more Bean collecting
oh it requires replaying the levels over
and over no way
that is annoying
I'm Mike Cosmic that's one of my
favorite games ever made
oh wait we gotta work together so
you guys want a cat
are you serious Hermione are you serious
are you serious Ron we're just going
you guys are just okay I'll just follow
your lead then
I'll just follow your lead
Hermione come on help us over here
please
move left to right to straighten your
water stream what is this dude
wow thanks for all the tips by the way
Shadow and uh there was somebody else
who was giving us tips
like I said I played this game but it is
certainly not fresh in my memory
inspector yeah yeah you pass the game is
the intended but to pass the third task
oh you have to replay levels to collect
Shields it's easier to find and download
oh I gotcha instead of having to replay
that
dude what an annoying mechanic right
was that just to kind of like
artificially extend the game you think
just to like make it more hours
but not really
whoa Hogwarts just exploded what's going
on
I don't think so
I don't think so come on guys we can put
out this fire here straighten your
stream
move left right dude why do the beans
just vanish into the wall it makes no
sense
got this game for my birthday when it
came out and actually
wait Tears of Joy or tears of like why
did you all buy me this game
I mean I would have been excited
back then I wasn't reading reviews as
closely as I do now
all right we sprayed the fire salamander
now let's just blast him with a couple
of these random spells
not Joy misery and Dread
oh that's too funny
I don't think I ever bought this game I
think I just rented it
all right wait we got more salamanders
I can't believe you have to collect
Shields you have to go back and replay
levels
help me guys there we go nice
and now I'm then I'm just spamming I'm
just spamming at that point
all right look at these look look at me
running through running through butter
here dodging this guy
wait is he not even I was like does he
not even attack unless I start
oh my goodness what was that Hermione
whoa in gorgio
wow and then he just explodes
your first PC games ever
nice
this so correct me if I'm wrong I'm
pretty sure this was the first one
where the console and PC versions were
pretty much the same because for the
first three they were they were quite
different
and then I'm pretty sure this is the
point where they
I mean obviously different controls and
performance and all that would be
different but
summon Rewards
nice oh we got even more
oh wait this is one of those things
right
this is one of those things I need to
collect
but I don't know how to collect it
almost identical I thought so yeah
you need a sugar mama what why do you
say that psalm
don't remember the character sliding
this much on the Game Boy Advance oh
that one might be a little uh
dude I just had a memory of didn't they
make this the PSP version
was very similar to this one
I do not remember the handheld the like
the GBA though
oh you want to pick up Alden ring
it should be uh going on some pretty
good sales now you would hope
I think I've seen it a couple of times
for like 40 or so but
I feel like by the end of the year wait
by the end of the year the year's over
come on get him help me guys help
but is that Hagrid now
or was that Moody again that sounded
more like angry
sounded way more like Hagrid welcome
Griffin storm my friends and I love this
game that see like they had some good
ideas I will give them that
I will give them that they definitely
had the seed
or you know multiple seeds of a good
idea
there's more of those
and who knows like I'm sure this game
was under a really tight development
timeline
but even if that's true like why didn't
you just like you had such a good
foundation with
with either chamber or Prisoner of
Azkaban we're a really good foundation
inflatus okay not in gorgio inflatus
what
oh we're supposed to extinguish the
Flames first
all right let me go there you go nice
job Ron I think Ron got that one
all dude there are so many beans right
now you can buy so many cards after this
all right so I think we need to put out
all the fires though no no no not Carpe
retract them Potter
has the potential for a good game it's
EA of course
yeah it was totally like
different developer too right
did EA I know he ate published it they
develop it too
he had eurocon like no wonder did the
first two PC games those were really
good
knowing mood what is this
a rabbit what in the world did Hermione
just transfigured oh dude
another early look
at where Hogwarts is he got some of
their ideas
EA Games challenge everything
all right let's
car paper attract them come on get the
bridge there we go all right Harry down
to 67 Health but I see a chocolate frog
here oh dude chocolate frogs do not
restore Health in this game okay
that's how I feel Ron
I need to summon these
okay all right oh that gave me some help
nice
get a move on hey relax Moody I'm trying
to get some health back so we can
survive this no I don't want that I
wanna
there's no way to lock on guys it's just
purely
wear your position
all right so we got that one
[Music]
oh dude he's literally standing on the
fire this could be bad nope not for Ron
or was that Hermione who just
can use that that's pretty awesome not
going
controls are so very wonky on it though
don't even know what a Gamepad is
nice
knocked me over too but it's okay
quiet Moody we got this under control
dude
just collecting a few beans
okay
wait why do we need to do better they're
gone
oh wait what
did he just glitch down there or
something
the most powerful spell in all of the
Wizarding World
that we never heard about all right run
over and pick up that Shield
okay let's go back up now
all right so it's open and now we get
whatever The Shield is
is that level two
new wait new area available Hogwarts
exterior
I don't think that means I can go
explore it though right
salt water more effective against
salamanders
not yet Cosmic my oldest reads quite a
bit though and he's probably ready for
at least the first couple
right now he's reading the heroes in
training books which are kind of like a
like an if if you're think Percy Jackson
but for even younger audience
that's what he's been reading lately so
he'll probably finish those and then we
might try like a Percy Jackson or
something
all right so defense against the dark
arts is done
and it looks like oh wait so you can't
go back
one more try wizard Shield to unlock the
next location
so you could go back and redo this
all right let's go
wait why is Moody's challenge locked
one more try wizard Shield
said one more but it let me start it I'm
so confused dude
I'm so confused
welcome guys thank you for the new
follows
all right hold on I want to go back
though I want to buy I want to buy some
more cards so we should have enough to
buy several with Harry now
yes Buddha one more month
I mean we're almost to the 30 day point
right
it's crazy all right collector's cards
Aries cards
all right we got two okay so some of
Harry's
do cost increase the power of Harry's
accio spell yes please
hello Amos Amos dickery
all right so let's buy a couple of the
25s
foreign
go ahead and do that as well
and see if I've unlocked anymore nope
just that first page
all right we have enough for all these
sten's hairy stamina might as well right
since they're split between
the characters
35 days uh what's up Panda welcome thank
you for stopping by over here
thank you guys all of you for uh
checking out a different
same person different Channel
different website
and also very different time of day from
our usual streams
but to all of you regulars who came over
from the YouTube channel thank you guys
very much appreciate you being here and
hanging out
for a few hours here as we make our way
through one of the worst received Harry
Potter video games
do I think we'll get a winner ASMR I do
oral I do
and I that I mean that's just based on
the fact that
they know the community loves those
they've already done three they were
very well received it's not something
that gives away a lot so yeah I I
definitely think we'll get one this
month at some point
all right so here's where I'm a little
confused though about this game guys so
this one says locked Moody's challenges
and I go over Hogwarts exterior
one more Triwizard Shield unlock the
next location
it's so weird that you skip Moody's
challenges or maybe I just did a moody
Moody's challenge that must be what it
is that must be what it is I'm not even
gonna try to understand it I'm just
gonna hop into the Hogwarts exterior
here
just gonna hop right into this one and
you know what we haven't played Ron yet
let's play as Ron this time
that way we can get some beans with him
all right so with Harry now yes we can
equip several dude I want to build up
accio though because to be able to
just do one of each
Jinx stamina and then accio
yeah sure that one
all right so Hermione will we're still
good on hers I'm doing well Clint doing
well how are you my friend thank you for
being here
hope you're having a good Tuesday
Morning evening afternoon depending on
where you're at in the world
yeah it could be trying to find the best
spot for the ASMR
wait I already hit the check mark why
are you
I guess I hit the wrong button
I hit the wrong button before
all right I'm gonna set myself an alarm
right now
oh I get so into streaming that I don't
want to forget to pick up my my youngest
does he's just in preschool right now so
he gets finished at about 12.
so let's see I'm gonna set an alarm for
I live pretty close to his school though
so we'll do
we'll do 11 45
mentors I hope so too
and I know there's been a little
confusion because
well I shouldn't even say confusion
because they really just I mean they
just haven't talked about it
oh is there something to find if I go
back this way
oh there is okay so this is kind of like
I guess their idea of giving you a
semi-open area to explore
now I don't know if we're supposed to
run this way and go inside
no we're not okay so we are supposed to
go that way and explore
but yeah so when it comes to Dementors
for Hogwarts Legacy they obviously
showed them in the first trailer the
revealed trailer
in what many I think correctly assume is
Azkaban but we don't know that for
certain
climb block dude what is going on
okay I see I see the vision here
oh yeah we gotta work together come on
guys we need you too Hermione oh you
need all three of them for sure on this
one
okay so we'll drop that one there
and then this one if it'll let us I want
to put it on top of that one
come on guys
up higher did Harry just fall off
I thought he fell off
come on
now we gotta
controls are really bad they're really
bad
back with food nice miles
yeah I'm gonna be I'm gonna go get some
food after after I pick up my son here
in a few
oh no we literally have to get it like
right beside it
okay right there what
it moved too far back
okay
okay wait does that have it
here we go I don't even know what I'm
looking for I guess just more Shields
yeah oh that's a little collectible
right
Jinx oh you just have to jinx the statue
to earn the reward for it
nice
IGN gave this a 7-2
no way that seems
ridiculously high to be honest wait
that's it
that's all I needed to do
what
maybe there's more in that area
there's got to be more in that area
right
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go back in there
and see if there's maybe you have to
find more of those Shields
never played these Harry Potter games
you didn't play any of them Panda the
first couple were pretty good four was
not so good five five was solid
six was
and then set the two seven games were
really bad really bad
all right so Moody's challenges are
still locked we need three more Shields
to unlock the next one wait so I'm
supposed to go back here why didn't you
guys just let me stay here what it
actually pulls you out of the level
that makes zero sense
zero cents man
collect a shield the level and then you
have to re-enter oh yeah just discovered
that inspector
what a bizarre game mechanic
Game Spot give us oh my goodness
hey what's up Neptune welcome
yeah James I know James been doing some
uh twitch streams as well every now and
then there are still several Shields to
collect I know Moody
sounds just so menacing
oh dark detector
Jinx all the dark detectors to earn
rewards
welcome ghost first time watching on
Twitch Gabe on YouTube nice Gabe welcome
my friend thank you for stopping by
I know this was just kind of a Spur spur
of the moment thing it's awesome to see
so many of you here
hanging out on short notice
I've been hoping to do it but when it
comes to my live streaming schedule
right now other than Tuesday evenings
everything is always so up in the air I
can never commit to it too far in
advance
wizard Harry
so really glad to see a lot of you here
hanging out
but yeah I really want to do more of
these more gameplay streams but also
more
like different times as well all right
so I'm not going to go back up there
that's where we already were
a retro guy gaming with the subscription
as well retro guy thank you so much dude
thank you very much for the subscription
enjoy your ad free viewing now on the
channel and then also all the emotes
which we need to update I need to update
those to my our other emotes
seen these before have you dude Moody's
voice is so beautiful
yeah I haven't seen these before have
you
come on wrong
and also Bobby with the follow welcome
Bobby thank you Perpetual fish with the
follow Neptune followed
thank you guys
game reviewers are questionable at best
right
point five from Nintendo Power what
foreign
I'm not sure I'm definitely gonna be
streaming it Buddha definitely gonna be
streaming it
it's not really sure where yet
like there's obviously
most of our audience is on YouTube so
that I mean that's nice that makes it
and we already have all the streaming
stuff set up there
which I guess we have the streaming
stuff set up here now too but man it is
a pain to
there's got to be an easier way I'm
gonna have to research this like with
OBS having to switch back and forth like
it resets I even have different scene
collections they're called
but it resets everything
and you have to I have to re-log in
so tonight like when we do our YouTube
stream I'll have to re-log in everything
on YouTube
and get the get the new chat all that
set up to the other one you have to log
out log back in
there's got to be an easier way
I guess could you just do like stream
elements uh or what is it
there's another one streamlabs I guess I
could do that for one
but yeah so I I don't know yet
we'll definitely keep doing our regular
Tuesday night stream to chat even when
the game's out I want to keep doing
those
but then we'll we'll have to figure out
what we want to do for the live streams
okay can we walk with the okay don't
need to walk it'll it'll just go that
far
nice
I keep wanting to spin the camera around
too which looks like you do have some
camera control but that like where you
guys see me moving right now that's
pretty much it
pretty much it very limited
oh wait did I miss a comment from uh
Perpetual fish
Saving Grace for Half Blood Prince was
the music you want to bafta nice
oh your friend Shadow guided sitting
here nice Perpetual fish and thank you
Shadow guided
or 37 with the follow and Mary's Studios
with the follow
also
stathy politics with the follow and
saccharin with the follow thank you guys
welcome
all right I'm too I'm way behind on
the comments now Mary thought you were
following already hey it's all good Mary
2005 absolutely right the fact that this
game was getting sevens and eights what
I thought this was very
poorly received
like if this if this game is an eight
then the first two the first three are
like tens right
relax Hermione I remember
dude Harry just got burnt oh he just
stood there
Harry get out of the way
streaming different than twitch Cosmic I
mean
the discoverability is very different
it's very different like YouTube they've
made a lot of improvements to the live
streaming
but in terms of like the gaming culture
it's still not like if you're live
streaming games twitch is still
I think still a little bit better
for talk shows podcasts like YouTube's
great which is what we normally do on
our Tuesday night I mean it's really
like a podcast
there's one hold on I don't want to grab
it yet though because as soon as I do
the level's gonna end
all right there we go
you know what I should probably go and
get the more difficult one first
what do you think
hey get back here no I don't want to
don't want to summon the shield
because the level will end watch
Hermione just walk oh good I was like
what if she walks over it and it just
instantly triggers
I think I'd rather go get the more
difficult one first
hey have a good one shadow guy thank you
for being here
I want to explain everything about how
it works frustrating to even look at
hey well don't worry at all about uh
some games like if I'm playing new games
I'll probably be like no back seating
guys please but for this hey back seat
all you want my friend back seat all you
want
I do not care just want to experience it
get through it
definitely one of the worst games in the
series indeed
played played and played this back then
I actually kind of like the seven part
two game really
I heard they did make improvements with
part two
this is worse than Deathly Hallows wow
small Shields are Collectibles big ones
are the are the ones
only at the end of the level
part two had Apparition that let you
move three feet
whoa that's funny I have now that's when
I haven't played at all
I probably should have just grabbed that
first shield that I came to but
I feel like it makes more sense to go
and get the most difficult one
which I don't even know what the most
difficult one is but
oh my goodness dude we got all kinds of
stuff going on over here
oh there's one right there
all right you know what let's go ahead
and grab this one
she gotta be kidding me
changed it up now
it changed it up
that's probably what you were dying to
say inspector wasn't it
oh my gosh
oh dude see here I thought I was being
clever
I thought I was being clever
and the game's like no these are mini
Shields now
even though they look almost exactly
like the other Shields you got that
ended your level
all right so you know what that means we
gotta go back we got to go back to that
other that first one
unlock it in the last 10 percent
foreign
I'm gonna try to play through them all
we'll see
I've been saying that for a while and
Dylan keeps holding me to it MCD there
in the chat
keeps holding me to it
I played through the first three uh I
feel like most of you here probably came
over from the YouTube channel but if you
for those of you who may have found me
through twitch and haven't seen the
YouTube channel so we posted Let's Plays
of the first
three Harry Potter games over there
the first one on PC the second two on
GameCube
and so ever since we posted that people
have been asking when I'm gonna do the
fourth and honestly
the the reason I've been I've been
putting it off is because
I was not ready for this I was not ready
but me having you guys here makes it
makes it so much easier to get through
trust me
a lot easier to get through
hey thank you to the new follows welcome
guys all right so apparently these are
just mini Shields so I need to go back
now
I need to go all the way back here you
know what let's see if I does it do
anything if I smash this
oh it did
some beans which all just
almost all of those beans immediately
flew off the side
immediately
all right see if we can destroy all
these actually
oh dude you know a shield is behind one
of them
you know a mini Shield there we go
there we go
oh my gosh silver that would be
hilarious and then and then like the
minis that I've collected they don't
carry over so I have to go back and do
it all again
imagine dude imagine
you've always been a Hufflepuff recently
put into Ravenclaw what
was that on like the official Wizarding
World
you should do the uh there's a website
out there
that has like all the Wizarding World
questions
Wizarding World questions
how am I supposed to get up there for
that one that does look like a big one
actually I went up there
wait is it gone
there it is it was like right up next to
the wall over here
yeah do the one with all the questions
and let that be your definitive answer
thank you
or if you are what is known as like a
hat stall if you have two that are
really really close
then
go with uh you get to choose right
that is actually a thing Sorting Hat
will take your choice into account
oh we gotta get that down somehow
you gotta get that block down
there's a gate over there
all right so you know what maybe
dude
I'm just guessing at this point
that one on top definitely looks like
the larger one
definitely looks like the larger one
I know Cosmic it's like
cosmate was here from the days when we
had like three four people
one being my bot one being Nico
one being my buddy Chris stallion
and then Cosmic there were a couple of
others who routinely came in
all right so I don't think we can get
that at this point I feel like we need
to get all the mini ones and then maybe
that will somehow lower this gate if not
well this is fairly early in the level
we'll have to come back here anyway so
I'm not too worried about missing
something right there
yeah try that one that's so the official
Wizarding World Wizarding World site
that one's good
I just wish it would give you an option
of taking all the questions on even on
that one
yeah there's another website it looks
very very similar like they really did a
great job with the design to make it
look so much like but it's just the
exact Wizarding World questions but all
of the possible questions so then you
can get you know a more
all-encompassing result
all right there's three of those little
guys
smash Tower supports with cauldrons
here you need to explode the column to
get the big Shield
explode the column
so I probably need to go back though
right inspector I know sometimes there's
a stream delay
a delay so you may already I may
I may be behind on that comment so I'll
wait I'm gonna wait here for a second
just tell me if I need to go back or if
I should stay where I'm at and smash
some sort of column here
oh but if I get that big one that will
end the level right
I should probably just go now and
collect all the mini ones
smash the column surrounded by the gate
okay
gotcha
all right so there's a column back there
to smash like we're
smashing these columns over here
like what even is this level by the way
right
where
of all the books that have great video
game material oh no
oh no
don't even try to collect mini Shields
oh my goodness that's hilarious dude
yeah what is the point of the mini
Shields then
want to see a speed run for this game 10
mini Shields makes one big Shield right
but so you just don't need them though
like it's not
I just assumed there was probably like a
set number like eventually I'll have to
collect all of them
all right so let's see we we can do
Moody's challenges now we can do the
Hogwarts exterior we need two more try
wizard Shields
to unlock the next location but I don't
think that's Forbidden Forest
I'm gonna go back one more time to the
Hogwarts exterior
Mary I don't know what is happening
so this is Harry Potter and the Goblet
of Fire
one of the
worst received of the Harry Potter video
games
and it was a very interesting
progression system so there's no open
world in this game unfortunately no open
Hogwarts that you could just roam freely
and explore instead it's done through
levels and you have to collect these
little tri-wizard Shields instead
ghost I took that one several others
that included the official test six out
of ten times came up with Ravenclaw
two were Slytherin one was wow still
several Shields to collect I have been
pretty much every quiz I've ever taken
I'm 95 of the time Gryffindor like even
before they had the official one I was
almost always Gryffindor
I got I've gotten Ravenclaw a handful of
times
but I mean I really would say it's as
small as like five percent dude I see
like I think I might have seen a shield
over I saw something kind of shimmering
over there as I slowly moved the camera
okay guess not
yeah Cosmic we had a really good
Christmas how about you
my son hey you were asking earlier about
he was into Harry Potter yet not Harry
Potter but he is he's getting really
into Fortnight my oldest
so I've had to dust off my fortnite
skills which were
never great they were decent at one
point in time they were decent
but I'm like nowhere near what I used to
be in that game but I've had to uh I've
had to relearn I've been playing with
him a lot
foreign
yeah so the only other one like that
Mary both Deathly Hallows games were
they also did not wait what oh my
goodness Hermione is she
oh man okay we do have a lot of beans
now with Ron too so we can uh
we can use those to buy some
foreign
some cards after this
I still can't get over how the beans
just the majority of the time just just
vanish in into the world
into the wall almost instantly they're
just gone
can't see why this may be the one of the
worst received right
Dylan so I was always
it's funny dude
I always said that he never they should
never take building out of fortnite like
it's one of the things that makes it
unique and it is
but it got to I feel like it got to a
point where people were just so
ridiculously good
an epic man I Gotta Give Them credit
they're so smart for for making a game
that can really appeal to like hardcore
players and Casual players for a time I
consider myself a hardcore player
but then it just got to the point where
to keep up
you just I mean you had to play so much
to keep up with how good some of these
players were
so now I'm a no build guy
ironically though my son when he plays
solo he's been enjoying the build mode
like really
so who knows dude maybe he'll become
like this cracked just insane Builder
he's already like
it's crazy how fast
you see them pick up on stuff at that
age dude it's so crazy
like just the reaction time and then
Leviosa like it feels like I'm playing
with with someone
you know three times his age
he's eight by the way for those of you
may not know
welcome welcome to the new follows
retro on Twitch right I know dude blast
from the past
all right so we just need to knock this
wall down actually hold on I should go
back though
all right wait a second
can I is there a way to get up here
okay wait you guys said destroy the
columns
I can just climb up on this one though
but I think I already make sure I
activated this yeah I did okay we
activated that
Ravenclaw Tyrell what's up dude
welcome
Guardian Leviosa yeah that's gonna take
me some getting used to if we stream
over here more often getting used to
everybody's different names
Ray attire is Nico guys
yeah why is this not
columns the thing is over now
also I need to just do this one
wait what
I know I can destroy these walls here
I'm just gonna go ahead and destroy all
of them
yeah MCD is uh Dylan guys we got Nico
and Dylan here hanging out
there you go Mary yeah yours is uh
easy to remember on both
yo what's up Ginny welcome
oh I just saw Eagle Eye with the follow
I recognize that name too what's up
Eagle Eye
oh maybe these columns back here
Beyond is probably like getting so
frustrated with me right now
it's like a love hate thing for
inspector Beyond they hate this game but
played it a lot so they know what to do
oh man okay hold on
so we use these little things
let me go over here just destroy this
wall
so I'm gonna destroy all these walls
that we can
okay I couldn't it didn't let me destroy
this one right here
by the way inspector totally fine with
you uh
the back seating like I said no problem
so yeah I think I must be in the wrong
spot or something
foreign no no the columns thing is over
now oh it's over now wait so how do I
get this one
this is the one I was talking about
oh you've been playing Through Fire
emblemary nice
when you live stream Mary are you mostly
on YouTube or on Twitch
for your for like your gaming
playthroughs
guys we've got to get I know what we
need to do
we need to get
that down
can we hit it with wingardium from here
let's see
oh oh that's just wrong all right come
on guys I need the team up here
Harry
Hermione
why did Ron just get thrown back like
that
oh Hermione stuck
come on Hermione
you can do it
Ron stay up here dude
all right we need everybody up here
everybody
where's Hermione
all right maybe Harry and Ron are strong
did Harry just jump back down for real
you know what maybe we can oh there we
go let's go Harry
no we need Hermione too
or you know what maybe we can use our
ancient magic ability
magical's extremus
literally does nothing
literally does nothing to make my magic
stronger
wow what a rip-off dude disappointing
ancient magic here Hermione come on come
on walk over here
walk over here Hermione
or Christian gamer a welcome or man we
got so many of the regulars from YouTube
over here hanging out okay here we go
Hermione dude she's moonwalking again
just get up here please
let's go dude
everybody cast yes
yes come on we gotta get it over that
gate
you have to bring it this way first oh
drop it yes let's go
inspector I bet you thought I was never
gonna get that one I bet he thought
I kept thinking he had to destroy to
like lower this I was making it too
difficult
although the game didn't make it easy
either with the positioning and lining
up of them all right so now we can go
this way
drop it like over there
all right we got quite a few beans with
all the characters now so
I know Blue Moon she did not look like
she was gonna
get a perfect casts whatever that means
no great casts hey we did combine casts
in that one come on now come on
or maybe that was uh oh it goes
character by character I guess
what a weird just like progression
system like who thought
I guess they decided like they wanted to
make the game longer so they just decide
let's instead of making this an open
area they can just explore freely
let's just have them keep coming back to
this one area Okay so one more Shield to
unlock the next location The Forbidden
Forest but I can also do Moody's
challenges now and we can actually buy
quite a few more wizard cards here
although they're not they're not the
wizard cards we all know and love
150 dude this one better be something
really good Harry Will cast two Jinx is
at the same time
pretty sure that breaks the cannon
pretty sure
pretty sure it breaks the cannon
lurking while you get ready for work
nice I know it's like it's not my usual
time it's so weird
when I stream it's on Twitch most of
them I upload the vods on YouTube gotcha
new Hogwarts likely tweet today I think
so yeah today's like kind of the first
day
return to work for a lot of people I
feel like with yesterday being the day
that most companies observed like the
New Year's holiday
this card cannot be equipped at the same
time as another Jinx style card
Cho all right we'll buy that one
that one was a 150 though all right
let's buy a cheap one now increases the
power of accio spell I like that one I'm
just gonna have that one powered up on
everything Maybe
I already said it I'll repeat Moody's
challenges are useless they don't
progress the game at all basically the
arena with some special goals nice thank
you inspector sorry I missed it earlier
that is good to know I'm not gonna do
any of those then
I'm only interested in progressing the
game all right let's just do one of the
25
I'm literally just doing this to collect
them nothing more
nothing more
okay they couldn't even get the wizard
cards right man they didn't even make
the cards the fun wizard cards
all right so let's go to let's go to
Ron's cards now
he's got 331
do I even need to do this either like
does it help me with literally
wait hold on this might be something
good actually Ron's Jinx will bounce
around multiple Targets this card cannot
be equipped at the same time yeah we
might as well right but I feel like once
you get the most the more powerful one
there's no point elwin what's up elwin
Elwyn thank you for stopping by there's
another name most people will recognize
most people from the YouTube
oh where you live until the seventh some
people even went back to work yesterday
actually which is
kind of crazy but I mean and of course
certain businesses always have to be
open right like my wife's and her so uh
but yeah
yeah for us here in the US it's kind of
like
Christmas Eve Christmas Day usually most
companies get give those off
and then New Year's Eve some places May
close early and then New Year's Day you
get off but this year where it fell on
Sunday
all right I don't even really care about
these cards anymore to be honest with
you guys
I just can't bring myself to care about
them although maybe I'll need to we'll
see what inspector says I might actually
need to um
I might actually need to
as we get later in the game we might
actually need that more power
all right so we still need one more
Shield so we got to go back to that same
level again because Moody's challenges
don't really matter they don't really
mean anything so back to the Hogwarts
exterior we go
I am going to apply some of those let's
see we'll go with Harry this time
and I really want to apply the one let's
keep the one for accio
but I think I have it an even stronger
accio one
oh no they're both just plus 10. okay
that's fine
okay that one's for the jinx
so let's do the one
Oh I thought I had one that
maybe I didn't buy the right one
instead of that let's just instead of
stamina I'm gonna do creature wait is
that new
gives the player an advantage against
salamanders oh that's kind of cool but I
don't feel like it's very useful right
now and then character
the group will start with the magic
meter they mean the ancient magic meter
guys
7 A.M when the stream started I know
Ellen I couldn't Nico was here right
away I couldn't believe it
I couldn't believe it
honestly I was like I'm just I'm not
even gonna tell anybody that I'm I'm
just gonna wait till a couple minutes
before this is really kind of a test run
make sure I remember how to work
everything over here on Twitch
make sure our night bot and everything
was working which nightbot is working
or says the cards aren't really worth it
just very time consuming gotcha good to
know
good to know
all right so let's do the Jinx one let's
do double jinx that way his Jinx is
gonna be
and if the stamina becomes a problem we
can always adjust that one later
now see like stuff like this like this
was actually a cool idea
but it just doesn't make enough of a
difference and the way it was
implemented
oh man
the way it was implemented is a little
rough
all right let's go with that go with
that go with that
Brandon what is up Brandon actually
booted up smash oh my goodness I don't
think I had a card set with Ron
oh well I'm not too worried about it
not too worried about it
yeah so over here L when Nico is Ray
attire r-a-y-a-t-i-r-e
hold on I gotta see what Brandon said
here about uh
about smash Brandon used to watch when
we play Smash
booted up smash for the first time in
ages New Beginnings nice man I haven't
played Smash in so long my kids will hop
on and play every now and then
but I haven't played in a while
86 Hufflepuff there you go
there you go we'll have to use the
culture actually Moody we have like
three times already because we've done
we have to do this level repeatedly
we have to do it repeatedly to find more
of these tri-wizard crests
it's gonna go straight through this time
by the way for those of you just
dropping in we are playing Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire
one of the worst received of the Potter
games
and it won't take you long to see why
so that's why we're streaming it man
because I could absolutely not play this
by myself and post it as a live stream
definitely need some chat to humor me
along the way
so I am glad that all of you guys are
here
by the way for anybody uh if you came
over from the YouTube so it works a
little bit differently here to basically
to to subscribe to the stream here it's
called a follow on Twitch so you just
follow the stream it's a little heart
icon
and then if you want to subscribe to the
stream that will unlock the emotes and
the ad free viewing over here and if you
have Amazon Prime it's you can actually
link it to your Twitch and it's free
so it's really really handy if you have
an Amazon Prime already you could just
link them up
by the way for anybody who is new and is
like what what's he talking about
YouTube maybe you found us through
twitch here today and you're not on
YouTube
we uh we have a YouTube channel we post
a lot of Hogwarts Legacy content
so I'm gonna type here right now there's
our our Discord so nightbot get the link
to the Discord
let me see I'm I really want to test
these out to make sure I set them all up
correctly
nice dude nightbot is way more
responsive on Twitch as well on YouTube
it it's it hesitates for a second
Oh no I got two okay I need to all right
that's see that's why we test it I need
to go and take it out for
need to take it out for one of the two
either stream elements or nightbot glad
our presence helps you through couldn't
do it either I know this is not the kind
of game that I would just like the other
ones the first the first three those
were actually fun to do I recorded all
my gameplay and it's on YouTube but
those were fun to do on my own you know
even though they would have been fun to
live stream too but this one like man
I'd be bored of Tears
bored to tears going through this one on
my own
sun is always like Splatoon practicing
for rank that's awesome
so my kids love the Lego games really
really love the Lego games
but I bet they would like Splatoon you
know what that's actually a really good
idea
I should I should get my oldest
invisible tune
I don't know like as much as I love
fortnite
I also worry about
like some of the monetization with with
kids
it's just like I don't know it's not I'm
not gonna call it dirty or sleazy but
but there is this sense of and I and I
picked up on it right away too because
when I first started playing with my son
I had to make him a completely new
account
and so I have all the these skins
unlocked
and just right away he doesn't have any
skins
so right away he like it's like this
feeling of being inferior you know
because you don't have the Skins we are
getting destroyed by these salamanders
right now
so he asked for some v-bucks for
Christmas and and I did buy him the
battle pass I was like okay
skins themselves are just like
ridiculously
expensive for like one cosmetic you know
but um so I got him the battle pass
because with that you get a lot you know
you unlock a lot as you go
oh dude we gotta put up this fire we
gotta put another Spire to stop him from
coming back
yes well two would be great they love
Mario Kart
and then they also they enjoy every now
and then playing some Smash Bros as well
the aspartoon would be a really good one
like especially oh I just dyed his hair
excuse me
I don't know what brought him back but
I'm glad it brought him back get out of
the fire though Harry
get out of the fire
all right there we go let's blast this
one
inflatus
so many made up spells in this one guys
like inflatus they literally already had
a spell for that it's in gorgio dude why
does
come on revive yourself Harry oh man it
must be that ancient magic dude
the ancient magic doing its job all
right I'm just gonna put off this fire
because this salamander keeps coming
back
okay there we go it's gone
back in the ancient times retro Channel
we grind right dude oh my gosh yeah some
late night streams late night smash
streams setting up the arena battles
even did a couple tourneys on stream
that was fun man
good times good times I still love smash
just don't have the time to devote to it
okay wait we didn't apparently didn't
finish this guy off here
dude Splatoon might not be a bad one to
stream either it'd be fun
ah
Fable got to be one of the greatest Xbox
franchises
Alicia what's up Alicia
hold on wait what's Alicia's name Lua
print over here
started a new job
good luck with the new job Alicia
yeah we missed you on the last
YouTube
Fall Guys oh Cosmic yes
they do love some Fall Guys Among Us I
haven't played any Among Us oh my gosh
dude Hogwarts Legacy YouTuber Among Us
stream
God I just just just had that idea
I feel like we have to make that happen
at some point now
maybe like after the game you know as it
starts to
the you know the hype starts to wane
from the game
just feel like all of us are going to be
wait what is the gate okay the gate's
open I'm just not lining it up right
all right let's take my time here
no
yeah I saw Fall Guys has like Encanto
Cosmetics right now
dude what am I doing wrong
I need you to go
there we go I just made it go quickly
that time
retrocad gaming sorry I missed your
follow earlier I'm gonna have to turn up
those the follow notifications I have
set to really quiet but I think they're
too quiet I'm not hearing them when they
pop in
all right so there should be another
Shield somewhere in this level
thought there would be a way to progress
further oh no completely botched that
one
I thought there would be a way to
progress further if we went this way
oh no Shield there more beans
multiversist dude I did I tried that out
very briefly and obviously saw the smash
inspiration
they gotta add Harry Potter to that at
some point right
right I mean it'd be crazy if they don't
add Harry Potter to that game
we destroy the fountains too oh you can
all right let's see if there's a uh
still telling me to smash support so
maybe I need to
no
axio
cracks me up that they just decided to
change the pronunciation in this one
kid would definitely watch a Splatoon
stream
smk if you enjoy it they will most
likely enjoy it
like it was something I I mean obviously
I'm not gonna force my kid I never
forced anything
but just seeing me playing and how much
I enjoy playing
it's just it was inevitable
it is interesting to watch their their
tastes in games develop though like my
youngest is four he'll be five this year
my oldest will be nine here in a few
months
it is fun to like see their like their
different tastes develop though in
gaming
my oldest his favorite game ever is
probably Super Mario Odyssey he's played
I mean he's played through that game
multiple times started new saves and
played
you got more moons than I did I know
cosmic's son loved that one too
all right well apparently this is not
the area we're supposed to be unless
unless unless we got one more Fountain
over here guys
one more fountain
Let's see we gotta go all the way over
there
nope
all right so I think we've destroyed
everything in this area
and have no more tri-wizard Shields to
show for it
I've collected this one already I
thought there might be more inspector
I'm sorry
oh you had to mute right after you heard
your name I said uh good luck with the
new job Alicia good luck with the new
job and we miss seeing you uh on the
last YouTube live
but I know you guys are busy you got
real world things you know
can't make every live stream it's
understandable
definitely understandable all right
I know I already got this one too
yep okay that's done
you're Batman fiend in the Multiverse oh
not at all
what
sorry inspector hey not wasting time we
did at least collect some beans
we did collect some beans
breath of the Wild on Master Cosmic that
is awesome
all right I'm caught up now inspector
I'm cada oh caught up
fell asleep oh man hey we all need our
rest too though
we all need our rest
no excuses
still in the bed oh my God
normally let's see I'm a night owl you
guys know this so I would be
it's 11 15 for me so I'd definitely be
awake by now but
all right so we're trying to find one
more
try wizard crest
inspector has been our go-to here for
helping us get through this
I thought I got everything over here
but maybe we missed something
fiance needs a ride to work at 7am oh
that is early but hey that's a good it's
being a good
fiancee right there
there we go
or wait I always get it is it it's
Beyonce fiance
I always I can't remember which one's
which
sorry for being so clingy hate people
wasting time
more than the game the game itself dude
you're all good like I said
back seating in a game like this I'm
totally cool with it
all right so we already did the thing
with that
we already did the the dark detectors
where to go next there's more wall
location on this level
there's more locations on this level
beside the wall location so wait back
like oh my gosh I almost fell off back
like at the very beginning
you think
foreign
what that is crazy Alicia
the guy she said my guy who did or the
guy who did my first aid training today
looked and smiled exactly like you what
too funny
to the right all right let's go
honestly Anaconda we need to update
those so twitch has a thing called
Channel points which you can like
I can set up fun little rewards like one
of them I know that we have set up is
called hydrate so you could redeem the
hydrate we used to have things for like
choose my character in Smash Brothers
when we were playing a lot of Smash
Brothers I honestly don't even know what
all I have it set up to right now
oh wait over here
but that's another reason I wanted to do
this live stream kind of low-key it's
like I wanna I need to make sure that I
have everything set up correctly that is
one of the things that I need to update
oh yeah this way this way this way
so I should be making a notes here
actually
that's in the game right
that's not like a creepy singing voice
in my house okay good
okay good I was I was panicking a little
bit there
yeah there we go there's a hydrate
okay so one thing I need to do is
delete Prime command
from stream elements
this is so creepy
still hate the creature oh no
oh no
oh yeah and then Channel points that's
the other thing I needed to do I knew
there was a second one
Channel points
all right let's move these rocks out of
the way
hydras when your day drinking starts
yo welcome thank you for the follow
like this
I hope the Hogwarts Legacy ancient magic
meter I isn't as pointless is this
ancient magic meter
even Moody is like teasing this
this creature I can't wait to see what
it is now
oh
oh even the sound dude
they're giving me chills that Nail's on
a chalkboard
creepy
nope
dude imagine when we're playing at night
in Hogwarts Legacy in the forest with
the uh
okay so I can just get by them okay good
I'm gonna turn around and there's just
gonna be 50 of them chasing me oh oh
dude what if they actually are back
there
they've taken Hermione no we must go
back for a run okay there she is
Hermione get get up here what are you
doing
come on everybody
Hermione
Hermione cast a spell
please before they get to us Hermione oh
my gosh what is she doing she's she's
literally Hermione get get
oh now Ron now Ron decides
Ron
Ron what
sheesh
there they are
oh dude didn't even
give me as a Dodge
watch out for darts
see there's the ancient magic
transforming them into a creature
Big Time slackers
hey have a good one Cosmic good to chat
with you glad to hear you're doing well
glad to hear your sons doing well
all right carpet retract him again guys
again
so you do only need two it just takes it
okay yeah just takes it a second
and
hold on hold on hold on just kind of
scan an area here before I grab that one
just looking for other areas that we're
gonna explore when we come back here
oh my goodness dude the aim on that guy
the AIM
oh no that was a mini Shield darn it we
continue
hold on how am I gonna fight him
can I cast okay he's kind of moving away
now
nope he's not moving away
dude are we gonna have to do no way the
game wants us to think this far ahead
right so we have to think this far ahead
do we have to use one of the rocks
to take this guy out where is he come
back over here
oh dude I missed him or no wait maybe
it's simpler
maybe we use the Rock
to like block us
come on run get over here dude hurry so
we go fight this guy
oh you have to make sure the spell cord
is fully extended
so maybe it'll even work if I was on
just Harry right there
oh they're everywhere dude
they're everywhere
what even are these things
hullus Ron's casting pullus on these
oh my goodness dude
I'm almost dead
but it seems there's no penalty for
dying unless I've missed something
now let's just like throw him off the
ledge dude
Hermione's just gonna say cast a full
tornado on him
foreign
just keep moving
oh the chocolate frogs
inspector Beyond coming in clutch again
let's see does it even show me how many
I have somewhere
probably not that'd be too easy
all right Hermione yes you get him like
that
Ron's bringing the rock over
wow Perfect cast
so wait that's what you have to do for a
perfect cast I guess everybody does a
different spell
there we go the chicken again
the ancient Magic
last time I died it showed 12 or so of
the frogs nice
yo jellyfish with the
subscription hey thank you so much
jellyfish
very much appreciated
enjoy your ad free viewing no ads when
you're a subscriber guys and then you
also unlock our Channel emotes
which are the old school twitch emotes I
need to bring over
all of the new ones I have some of the
new ones
but not all of the new ones that we have
over on YouTube
there we go there we go now Dodge now
Dodge
it's so weird not having like a lock on
button
oh yeah didn't mean to do that but hey
we're going with it now
dude just look at all these fireworks
magicus
extremus
oh wow he just got obliterated dude it
literally is like the ancient Magic
it's like the ancient Magic
there you go Ray attire I can't I just I
can't get in the habit of calling you
that Nico I still think I'm gonna call
you Nico
Nico showing off the emotes that we have
over here on this channel thank you Nico
hype train is close what sub gift or use
bits now to start a hype train wizard
well that's cool
Elwyn with the twitch Prime subscription
as well
Ellen thank you so much
enjoy your ad free viewing on the
channel
so that is one uh Cosmic I think
cosmic's gone now but Cosmic was asking
earlier about differences in YouTube and
twitch
so they both have their pros and cons
one of the I would say cons of twitch is
the ads you do not get much
you basically have to have ads on Twitch
whereas YouTube I think you can like the
whole stream can go without any ads and
then if you watch the VOD there will be
ads on it
but unless I choose to run an ad on a
YouTube live stream it won't happen
twitch they automatically happen
periodically so if you guys have gotten
hit with an ad at any point while trying
to enjoy the stream my apologies
nothing I can do about it unfortunately
unless unless I like set aside specific
time oh we're so dead
unless unless unless
hold on can we do do we have our
superpowers no we don't we have to get
it dude the ancient magic meter
I was kind of joking in the beginning
but you see how it's like it has like
two segments just like the one for
Hogwarts Legacy
I do wonder if they were somewhat
inspired by that this is the last Potter
game I would want to take inspiration
from but
oh no okay there we go yep 12. now we
just dropped down to 11.
on the chocolate frogs
but yeah so one of the benefits of the
subscription here is that anytime you're
watching the channel you won't have any
ads yo there we go with another blue
moon
with the twitch Prime subscription as
well thank you Blue Moon
welcome to house rack and tour
oh that's another thing we should work
on um
I'll ask Nico about that later if we
could somehow integrate that with
Discord as well we have a special
Discord role guys for YouTube members
we could set that up for
twitch Subs as well
and then Elwyn with a gifted tier one
to Jewel xhd Ellen thank you so much for
the gifted
Ellen always be gifting out memberships
on our YouTube streams
thank you very much Elwyn so yeah all of
you who uh just got a subscription
no ads now as you watch the Stream
dude I'm just going all in on this guy I
know our health is really low again
come on maybe that'll give me a little
bit
it did but not enough
no I don't want to do that I want to I
want to try to oh good he I was about to
say he should not be able to run in the
fire
we're almost there we're almost there
we're almost there guys
just wanted to see what the hype train
thing was we hit a level one hype train
it popped up
I don't even really know what it does
either
we're at a level one hype train though
we did we hit it we made it happen
all right so now I think we just need to
put out the fires
the names of the creatures I believe
they call are called oroklings
Earthlings
always struggle with how you pronounce
that word earthlings I guess
that sounds right
I feel like I remember um
I definitely remember reading that in
some of my there we go we got a perfect
cast
oh wait somebody got 13 perfect casts
and somebody got zero I'm probably the
one who got zero
I don't know how you can't get a perfect
cast do you know that the answer to that
inspector how do you get a perfect cast
like what is it based on because I
literally just feel like I'm spamming
buttons
that's all I feel like I'm doing when I
run through the level or when I cast
spells it's just Spam spam spam
very button Magic game so repetitive
right
ah man I was hoping there was something
more to it silver
I get yeah I guess it's just literally
like just get everybody in the chat
excited about
Subs memberships follows all that
the real question should be are those
are they gonna be an Hogwarts Legacy as
tameable
right the fact that we have
that whole area with the uh
you know the vivariums inside the room
of requirement is just like and I feel
like
they wouldn't make all that unless they
had a lot of creatures you know
like why would you make that if you had
like five creatures
I think it's gonna be a lot man I do
fried broccoli tempted to buy a
PlayStation 2 and get all the HP games
so
I don't think you could get all of them
on PS2 because
let's see the first one is on PS2 the
first three are on PS2 I believe
believe the first three are on PS2
the fourth one I think is as well and
then after that I'm not sure after that
all right I think
dude another we had another gifted
membership this one from Nico gifting to
archmage097 arcmage
congratulations on the gifted sub there
from Nico Nico thank you so much for the
gifted
yeah I definitely need to turn up the
alert sounds
put that on my notes Here
I even made a special one I don't know
if you guys are able to hear it
for the uh whenever membership or
subscriptions are gifted
DJ and confetti thank you guys for the
follow welcome
Half Blood Prince was the last PS2 okay
so you can play most of the good ones
then
you can play most of the good ones oh
and we unlock emotes for it okay that's
kind of cool you received a level one
hype train emote
share
there we go thank you guys I guess you
all just unlocked that now that's pretty
cool
so there is a slightly more incentive
see how this tab works okay my emotes
oh yeah and then all mine must be at the
top here
oh yeah we definitely gotta update these
we gotta get more of the
we have quite a few more over on YouTube
now we gotta add more over here
okay how do I get that to go away there
we go
everyone who participated in the hype
train gets an emote nice thank you
silver
thank you thank you
all right I think I have enough time oh
it's gonna be close
you know what I should probably let's
try it we'll see if I have enough time I
got about 10 minutes before I have to
leave to pick up my son
any New Concept for Hogwarts Legacy oh
yeah
not today
uh most likely tomorrow so my next one's
gonna be on combat
and then I thought about doing a
rebuttal to so one of my favorite uh I
shouldn't say favorite but a YouTuber
that I
because I don't watch him a lot but I
have I've he has some of my favorite
videos and I've started to become more
familiar with this content is a guy by
the name of Luke Stevens he does very
very in-depth thoughtful
um just like really looking at the
nitty-gritty of games like really diving
deep I mean he has like I'm talking
several hours videos that he uh
oh I should make Ron more powerful
against those dudes
and he recently posted one on Hogwarts
Legacy
a Skeptics
guide or something I think a skeptic's
view of Hogwarts Legacy preview
something like that
a lot of really good points a lot of
really good points but I thought it
might be fun to do like a rebuttal to
that video
but I think I might just do that on
tonight's live stream so we will be
having our regular YouTube live stream
tonight as well guys for anybody who's
wondering
all right here we go Forbidden Forest
he had something important to show you
all right so this is Hagrid tipping us
off on the first task
you saw that one too yeah
and so I mean I don't think he was
taking a shot at I don't even know I
think he knows my channel exists because
he retweeted me the other day I was like
oh that's cool
but um I don't think he was taking a
shot at our Channel he made some
comments
about some people like you know just
typing up the game for easy views
I don't think he was talking about us
probably talking about some bigger
channels that maybe haven't like covered
the game and then are just kind of
jumping on now like hey here's here's
all this get hyped
but I feel like
I mean I feel like we've kept a pretty
level head
for for being as deep in Hogwarts Legacy
as we are like I feel like we've done a
pretty good job
but but what I really want to talk about
what it really sparked in my mind is
this like whole idea of hype thank you
guys for the follows by the way just saw
a couple new follows drop in there
never watch your Twitch before retro hey
well DJ thank you for being here my
friend we we haven't streamed in a while
over here it's been a while thank you
for stopping by and following though
but what that video really made me think
about is like this whole idea of hype
oh don't jinx them you'll burst okay
sorry we got a catapult the bubble tuber
pull them this way maybe
this way come on
come on
oh and then I have to let go
catapult so I bet I'm gonna have to like
launch him can I launch him like over
there
Perfect cast
and yet nothing happened
there he goes there we go we launched
him right there
oh we launched him
oh but he's back wait why did he come
back
I guess we're just supposed to get by
him and then leave
um
but yeah like this whole conversation
around height
and how like by setting your
expectations
accordingly helps you avoid
disappointment
I definitely think there's some truth to
that I I watched a video another video
of one of my other favorite YouTubers
there's a
this guy's name's Ali abdall
and he interviewed a gentleman who wrote
this book called I think it was called
the happiness equation
and he
to just like very very simple terms
why am I not watching this dude he says
happiness equals events minus
expectation
oh I think we need to launch him into
that though and then I wonder if it will
like clear it out
so he's like if that guy that he
interviews he says like if you want to
end life like if you want to optimize
purely for happiness then yes you should
just go around with completely low
expectations like
but
but he argues that for a more like I
don't know just a more healthy enjoyable
approach is you want like a happy medium
realistic expectations
so I've had all these thoughts kind of
going around in my head on this whole
idea of like realistic expectations
versus needless hype like that's what I
I always try and avoid is I don't want
to Hype people up on you know something
that may not actually be in the game or
I don't really know what to do here by
the way don't really know what to do on
that section we'll come back to it
but and the other part that I feel like
it doesn't account for like I feel like
all of this like this our hype that
we've been having for months
the talks the conversations we've had
the theories that we've had I feel like
that is part of the event for me
like I'll tell you guys right now if
Hogwarts Legacy came out and it bombs
like let's just say that the game runs
awful
which to me like in my mind that's
really the only way this it could
totally bomb is if it just runs terrible
I mean like worse than cyberpunk you
know it's just like game breaking
if that happens I still wouldn't regret
all the stuff that we've like all the
theories and all the videos I wouldn't
regret any of that
because that to me was part of the event
you know that was part of the lead up
that was part of
just all of this you know I love the
hype I do and maybe it's partially
because I grew up reading the Harry
Potter books and getting so hyped in
between each book
maybe that's why
but I feel like I mean you know you want
to be healthy with it right you don't
want to if you go in expecting Hogwarts
Legacy is a 10 out of 10 it's going to
be better than Eldon ring it's gonna be
the best game ever made like I'm just
sure of that I'm sure of it
then you're probably setting yourself up
for disappointment right but if you have
a healthy like realistic expectation
based on what we've seen like I've I've
already seen several people say and as a
die-hard Harry Potter fan I agree like
what I've seen so far
if it was literally just a walking
simulator I would enjoy it like would I
be like this is an awesome game no but I
would enjoy just walking around that
world and collecting things like
literally if that's all it was
so we'll we'll probably talk a lot about
that tonight on stream just this idea of
hype and expectation especially now that
we're so close I mean it's right around
the corner it's right around the corner
guys
game told you to catapult the Bubba
tubers into the shrooms and make them
disappear did I not hit that that's what
I thought I was supposed to be doing
or does it mean like the little
mushrooms we'll go back let's try it
I saw somebody uh what do I think about
the points
points he made about the paywall
those are good points they're good
points like I don't like that the dark
arts pack
is essentially behind a paywall I don't
however I don't think we know enough yet
either now to his point he's like
talking about the history of WB like
with
with um
is it not long is it like not getting
over there
okay wait maybe right I see like there
is some sort of little cursor
oh my gosh I just didn't hit it earlier
he's looking at the history of WB
and like with shadow of uh shadow of War
Shadow of Mordor was the first one I
think
oh there we go but it didn't hold on is
that enough for me to get through there
so we got it
I don't feel like we know enough about
the dark arts Arena yet you know
like you said there's two more Arenas
well if they're pretty much the exact
same it's just like different spells but
you can unlock the dark arts anyway then
you know I don't think it's as big of a
deal
but if that one's like significantly
different then yeah and it is like it is
always unfortunate when you see that
stuff like even before the game releases
but to their credit and I don't think
they would go back and lie on it
is the website says no micro
transactions
so you would hope that there's not going
to be
any more of that
at least not they're not gonna be
nickel and diming on cosmetics and such
Sherry or Shari slays my favorite HP
game was Chamber of Secrets that one was
so good
yes I have a let's play up of that one
on the YouTube channel that's probably
my favorite actually that one is
probably my favorite
the console version but I've even heard
that the PC one is is better
I've started the PC one
but I haven't finished it
a couple of streamers who are excited
about the game and they saw the second
preview disappointed saw yet another
commercial empty open world game tons of
boring side quests
yeah the people saying it's empty like I
don't see that at all I do not see it as
being empty
now if you want to talk about boring I
mean we just don't know right
are there going to be fetch quests I
guarantee it yeah I guarantee it
okay so we got more of those over here
I hate that these come back they should
stay gone
they should stay gone
and why can't I not just climb up on
this right here
yeah that's true as well Jenny
yes a lot of the the Wizards unite
community that we're so passionate about
that game it's given them something else
to look forward to good point
[Music]
but I'll hold it suck on a lemon she
Owen says oh man
that's too funny
like see that's an area where
even if it is just like Skyrim style for
the for the quest I'm fine with that I
really am like I'm hoping for more
I'm hoping for more
but with the world they've built
honestly even if it's just like the the
fetch hey this dude's over here doing
that go collect these
as long as they're not all like that you
know
then then that would get boring and
repetitive I really have no idea what to
do I'm sure inspectors like screaming at
me down in the comments and I just
haven't caught up to it yet
oh man
or I feel like it's just like a DLC as
long as they're not making me buy a
flying Mount or horse armor
the mount I guess the Onyx hippogriff is
like a pre-order
and then there is the whole thing with
haunted hogs me like the PlayStation
exclusive stuff
many Shields are affected by accio
yes it is it is my alarm just went off
guys my alarm just went off
so I think I'm gonna have to call it
there
um I don't live too far so my